but in the real world our growth is set
to be slower than every g20 country
except one
russia
and our inflation our inflation is going
to be double the rest of the g7 does he
think that denying the facts staring him
in the face
makes things better
or worse
for working people
[Applause]
mr speaker the facts are as the imf has
said that the uk came out of coded
faster than anybody else that's why we
had the fastest growth in the g7 last
year that would not have happened mr
speaker if we listened
to captain hindsight and his and if he
studies if he studies their forecast we
will return uh to being the fastest uh
by 2024 and the fastest in 2025 mr
speaker and that's what the ims forecast
say he asked about he let's read it he
asks about working people mr speaker
this is the government this is the party
that supports working people
unlike them with the biggest increase
with the biggest increase
yes yes i'll tell you what's going up
the living wage is going up mr speaker
by record
amount employment is going up mr speaker
by recorder max 500 000 more people
they don't want to hear let me just
let me give them the figures
500 000 more people in paid employment
now than there were before the pandemic
began and youth unemployment youth
unemployment at or near record lows
under labour just remind you everybody
under labour youth unemployment rose by
45
[Applause]
mr speaker
this must be the oxford union debating
skills we've been hearing so much about
failing to answer the question
rambling incoherently
throwing in garbled metaphors a powerful
stuff prime minister
here's the problem
it's not just his words that are
complacent it's his actions as well
the cost of living crisis was blindingly
obvious months ago
but he said worries about inflation were
unfounded
and he backed a tax hiking budget
does he think that his choice to be the
only leader in the g7 to raise taxes
during a cost of living crisis
has made things better or worse for
working people
mr speaker as i've just explained to the
house and i'll repeat it uh once more uh
this government and our chancellor cut
taxes on uh working people uh the
national insurance contribution uh went
down uh mr speaker by an average of 330
pounds but if he's if he's talking about
if he's talking about the health and
care levy maybe he's talking maybe
that's what he's he's droning on about
look at the health and care levee mrs
bigger that is what is enabling us to
pay for 50 000 more nurses to pay for
clearing the kovid backlogs how tragic
how pitiful how pitiful that the party
of bevan should now be opposed to that
investment in the
nhs speaker
mr speaker
he's an ostrich
perfectly happy keeping his head in the
sand
working people are worried about paying
their bills
they're spending less and cutting back
that's bad for business and bad for
growth
working people are looking for help but
this week
millions will look at their pay slip and
see a tax rise with his fingerprints all
over him
does he think that his 15th tax rise
has made things better or worse for
working people
[Applause]
mr speaker what we're doing for for
working people is not only lifting the
living wage by the by the record amount
uh helping people on universal credit
within a thousand pounds tax cut mr
speaker but also cutting national
insurance contributions lifting the
threshold so that on average people pay
330 pounds less mr speaker but what
we're also doing is taking our country
and our economy forward investing in our
nhs which is a priority for the people
of this country unlike for the labour
party mr speaker but also ensuring that
we have record creation of jobs mr
speaker and that is what matters high
wage high skill jobs half a million more
they don't care about jobs if we go we
do we do we believe in high-wage
high-skill jobs and that's the answer
for the economy